what's up guys it's Gary Vaynerchuk
d-roc and I've been jamming this mainly
my idea Saudi rocks they come I want to
start making some videos where I talk
over content that is over indexing in a
lot of people's point of view we put out
a lot of content this is a Tech Week
Talk I don't even actually know what I'm
about to watch though now I'm
remembering so I don't to [ __ ] you I
recall so be interesting but expanding
on pieces of content I don't want to
call you need to come you know what
leave a comment for I want to create a
name for this series expanded extra
minute off-the-cuff beyond the 13th hour
you know about 25th hour probably a
little bit better anyway I want to
create a series where I sit down I watch
video and talk to you about what's
running through my thoughts or expand on
something just to create more content
more context around the content that
already over-index said feels like this
is a very good five to six minute video
series that I think would actually get
some serious legs first time you're
hearing about right heard of it cool
right you like it yeah it's good yeah
all right so here we go this was from
Tech Week ooh this could be cool it was
an early morning I had a rush I was
running late and then they ran late it
was past I was like every minute counts
what else happened felt really good
Bryan is an amazing host of seeing on
CNN first time I really got to engage
with him really thought he did a good
job in the interview good listener which
i think is the key and it felt really
good it felt like good vibes small room
nothing too crazy big name tech week and
so let's see if I hit play and I would
open up and here we go yes
he loves my commentary on it cuz I'm
dissing the younglings along the way for
you know we can just and and propel at
all points I absolutely believe that
people in their twenty to twenty five
year old range have a lot of audacity
around being compensated I think they're
massively skilled I think Millennials
are grossly underestimated especially
twenty to twenty-five I dominated at
twenty twenty-five and built a huge
business so I have a lot of empathy for
it AJ is a was a dominant force at
twenty to twenty five so I believe in a
tremendously I do think that a lot of
people get clouded by all the eighth
place trophies and think they're better
than they are because they've never
played in the market they played in
school and under their parents watch
that's a very different game so he's
dissing along the way so he likes it but
on the flip side he was only hearing one
part of what I was saying about that
demo which is why this got a little
interesting you think they're not
skilled or work don't work hard I do
think that there is a little bit too
left to be desired on the work ethic on
the hours but honestly I'm I'm actually
envious I think I think this generation
is spending their money on better things
the reason they're working a little bit
less is they are working out for an hour
longer they are balancing their their
interests their jobs aren't their whole
worlds they're not like throwing their
whole world into GE right they are
rounding themselves out India does art
on the side like everybody's doing their
thing like I love that I actually think
it's a very smart strategy and I think
most 40 to 50 60 year-olds are envious
of the ability to build multiple tunnels
back to that 80/20 that I did an episode
156 of the askgaryvee show you know I
think that um I think that's a very
important part so I think the reason
they're not putting as many hours is
they can't buy into the Corporations
because their corporations aren't there
for them they're smarter they understand
they have options they have the Internet
as a platform they don't need to grow up
the ranks of a corporation so I think
they're being more strategic plus
instead of buy 42 inch screen TVs or a
fancy new car like this guy probably did
if we're generalizing you want to
generalize that generalize you so
instead when you were 26 you want a fat
whip right what instead they're going to
Coachella or to Berlin for the week or
like you know they're experiencing which
i think is way more valuable I think the
products are commoditized
they don't like it when I tell them that
and only because you know parties when
I'm working with them and some of them
have a chance what's your perspective on
dealing Supercenter nasty day one guy
how do you get introduced to that
without telling them they're stupid like
I I actually I actually think of it in
Reverse
I mean most of my 22 and 23 year olds
would look in their face and think that
you're finished I'm like [ __ ] you this
is what kinda interesting for me so
saying that to him and now he's saying
I'm gonna make money for them might make
money fall outside now I'm starting to
sense a different thing in this question
like okay what is he really talking
about because if you're so good at
making money and make it fall outta sky
why are you giving it to 22 year old
give this lazy ass Johnny give it to
yourself but it's not it's not about
cool what have you you what you define
as money might be different than the way
they define is money like okay cool how
much what are you gonna make for your
torso at this point I have no idea what
he's talking about with money so I'm
thinking about $100,000 or 55 I don't
really even know what he's talking about
this point this is where I got
interested four-year-old give you know
now forty million dollars now I'm
confused completely because the first he
said he was gonna make money for them
now I'm thinking maybe he owns his own
company the company will make forty
million dollars in revenue so I'm trying
to go down the path of like cool if your
company makes $40,000 revenue you're not
given 22 year-old Johnny anything my
whole point was what are you actually
giving somebody you might be giving him
$50,000 so how do you expect them to
work 90 hours and did you create
meritocracy like I have at Vayner where
people know they can move up just
because they're good enough not because
they have to check all the boxes along
the way so that's where I was digging
here but it took a different turn Rick
doesn't get 40 million dollars how much
does Rick the twenty three-year-old get
and give me the truth because the number
isn't high
now I'm very can explain explain further
I want about how a 23 year old okay I
have an old school web strategy yeah I
know what works so we have some question
yeah why don't you just do it for
yourself yeah that's the real question
right like cool okay what the [ __ ]
you're talking about do for yourself
I do I work harder and I'm smarter than
all my 22 year olds I'm better at social
media than everybody I may know me down
looking at stray that just to remind
that I was like it so so so honestly I
think you're rolling with like trying to
razz them razz yourself like why are you
trying to funnel through a twenty
three-year-old thank you and so so I
think you know what's interesting there
was and this is where this can we can
expand on this is way too many people
are looking for excuses and saying like
I can help you I can help you help
yourself if you're so good at making
money make it for yourself and and and
more importantly everybody's using the
excuse right now in this millennial
generation people are picking on the 20
to 30 year old that's scale it's very
convenient I think it's a high level of
jealousy I don't think I didn't grow up
in it I think a lot of my fourteen fifty
year old friends didn't grow up in it
it's never been a better time to be 20
to 30 years old the world is absolutely
your oyster the Internet is incredible
surround yourself the only reason I
think that people should work here is
because that I'm that special I'm not
kidding as egotistical as that sounds I
think I could be a gateway drug that
creates a lot of opportunity for them
but if you were not lucky enough to work
in an organization and or an individual
that creates a huge leap frog for you
for what you want to do then there's so
many amazing options or what I think so
many Millennials are doing proper which
is they're putting in their eight hours
and they're doing it the best they can
and as hard as they can and they're
spending other hours doing other things
to create some opportunity that's the
right model in this world right now when
things are good I talk about being a
wartime general versus a peacetime
general I do believe there'll be an
economic meltdown like they're always in
and then he cycle between tomorrow
morning and the next ten years and when
that happens it was smart that those
Millennials went to Berlin
and did all those things because that's
when you get to experience it cuz your
life is gonna get real practical if
you're an average 27 year old right now
and [ __ ] hits the fan in six years
you're gonna have to get more practical
double down on that job now you're maybe
married you might have a kid on the way
not so easy to go to [ __ ] Coachella
for the weekend anymore so I think
they're playing it very right
intuitively don't forget a lot of these
people are kids of a generation where
they don't remember fully the last
meltdown there were 13 14 15 16 17 it's
been all good times they've grown up
with the imagery of zux and all these
startup founders everything feels
possible and I think that's amazing do
they work hard for a company that
doesn't care back for them well that
makes sense to me the reason I get mad
if somebody doesn't work hard here is
they haven't stiffed out that I'll give
back to them then it'll give back to
them and so you have to run an
organization like that it's a very
special time we need to stop dissing on
the Millennials so we need to start
looking ourselves in the mirror the
screen went black here so I can look
look yourself in the mirror and say
forget about worrying about how great
they have it or they don't work hard or
they don't care or they're aloof or they
can't talk to each other because they're
on their phone all day start looking at
yourself and start realizing you're
gonna live a much longer life than you
think what are you gonna do for the next
20 years I do I work harder and I'm
smarter than all my 22 year olds I'm
better at social media than everybody at
vaynermedia I'm looking at them right
now just to remind them like so-so